hey guys it's februari 28th I'm chasidy
I'm jess's back next week but you're
stuck with me for now so deal with it
just kidding I've got some news for you
but first hit subscribe so you never
miss any news updates you do it all
right let's go
first up Xbox one is getting a Netflix
like subscription service called Xbox
game pass Microsoft has announced Xbox
game pass a service that offers quote
unlimited access to over 100 great xbox
one and xbox 360 titles as part of a
monthly subscription of 999 per month
the service is expected to launch late
spring 2017 and will be available only
for Xbox one as detailed on the Xbox com
website games include halo 5 guardians
payday 2 NBA 2k16 and Lego Batman new
games will be added to the catalog of
games available on the service every
month as others are removed games are
downloaded directly to your console and
play online or offline in full fidelity
without any streaming or connectivity
issues those that subscribe will also be
given a 20-percent discount on
purchasing a game from the catalog and
ten percent off all related add-ons
discounts to add-ons are only available
while the base game is currently in the
catalog Xbox Live Gold is not required
to play xbox past games though you'll
still need a gold membership to play
multiplayer in those titles those that
are part of the Xbox insider program
will be able to test Xbox game pass in
the Alpha preview ring starting today
with a very limited number of titles
next up details on all four expansions
of battlefield one EA and dice have
announced details for all four upcoming
battle field 1 expansions available as
individual purchases or as part of the
games $50 premium pass the first
expansion called they shall not pass
gives players a chance to play as the
world war one error French army fight
across four French maps and take control
of the chart to see tank the game's
newest behemoth class vehicle the second
expansion is called name of the Czar in
which players will take control of the
Russian army and ride with the legendary
kazars taking part in the historic
Brusilov offensive and the Albion
assault the third is turning tides which
will have a naval focus a new destroyer
and coastal class airship will be
available and players will take part in
the zeebrugge arrayed and storm the
beaches of Gallipoli finally the
apocalypse expansion will include the
most infamous battles of World War one
and introduce the brutal tools and
unique weapons born out of desperation
and deadlock so look forward to a chance
to descend even further into the hell of
war those that commit to the premium
pass will receive all for expansions
including
two weeks of early access as they're
released priority server access and 14
superior level battlepacks full of
in-game cosmetic unlocks and finally
Ubisoft is giving us a new avatar game
but not the last airbender the james
cameron one sorry the new avatar game
based on the james cameron movie series
is in development at the division studio
ubisoft massive the game will run on the
developers proprietary engine snowdrop
the new and untitled avatar game is
coming to unspecified consoles and PC it
is described as being cutting-edge
though no details were provided about
this a teaser video has been released
featuring commentary from people at
Ubisoft massive and Cameron himself note
that everything you see in the movie is
from 2009's avatar not the new game and
no gameplay footage has been released
little is known about the new avatar
title apart from the fact that it is set
on Pandora from the movie series four
sequels are in the pipeline and Ubisoft
said it is working alongside Cameron's
film company like storm entertainment &
Fox interactive on a game that will
quote continue to expand and deepen the
Avatar universe and exciting and
innovative ways along with the film's
Ubisoft did not specify when they're
expecting to launch the new game be sure
to hang out with us tomorrow on the
lobby the lobby is life every wednesday
at 11am pacific time this week we're
talking about the switch breath of the
wild and middle Earth's shadow of war so
you won't want to miss it good stuff for
now hang out with me in the comments
down below about today's stories and
I'll see you next time
you